welcome to CBS this morning on this very
historic day for our country we of
course have breaking news and the world
is watching
the White House where President Trump by
all indications is about to become just
the third president in US history to be
impeached by this evening the House of
Representatives will vote on two
articles of impeachment abuse of power
and obstruction of Congress the question
for lawmakers is this did the president
break his oath of office by asking
Ukraine to investigate his political
rivals for his own gain the president
made his feelings very clear yesterday
in an extraordinary six-page letter to
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi accusing her
of quote declaring open war on American
democracy
our team of correspondents will cover
this dramatic and unfolding debate
throughout the day we begin with Nancy
Cordes on Capitol Hill Nancy where do we
stand
good morning Anthony the House gavels in
for this historic day at 9:00 a.m.
Eastern there will be six hours of
debate on impeachment evenly divided
between the two sides in a letter to her
Democratic colleagues last night speaker
Pelosi said that the house would be
derelict in its duty if it did not act
and with nearly all House Democrats
behind her it appears the votes are
there to impeach President Trump we're
in a search for the truth here this is
not a game months of debate and
investigations and hearings have led to
this the first House vote to impeach a
president in 21 years well we are here
to support our president there were
rallies across the country last night
most of them pro-impeachment with more
planned for today the nation as divided
as Congress he tried to shake down the
government of Ukraine to basically get
dirt on his political opponent to help
him in the upcoming 20/20 election there
will be a day of reckoning the calendar
and the clock will continue but what you
do here and how we have trashed the
process and getting here will live on
today the house will vote on the two
articles back to back article one is
abuse of power article 2 obstruction of
Congress but I'm hearing from from
people who say look
I might not agree with your position on
this but you know I trust the fact that
you're willing to bow your conscience
the legacy of the 116th Congress will be
defined by their hatred for President
Trump the yeas are 228 the nays are 206
the Clinton impeachment vote in 1998 was
less partisan but just barely just five
Democrats broke with their party in
favor of articles of impeachment this is
a political process the Senate leader
Mitch McConnell made no bones about the
fact that his views on a Senate trial
have changed now that it's a Republican
facing impeachment have you done a 180
on this I think it's pretty safe to say
and a partisan exercise like this people
sort of sign up with their own time and
what we may have felt twenty years ago
may not be the same as today Minority
Leader Chuck Schumer do you want someone
who proudly says they are not impartial
to be on a jury
judging high crimes and misdemeanors
some House Democrats have suggested
waiting to send the articles of
impeachment from the house to the Senate
once they are passed in order to prevent
what they see as a sham trial a
leadership aide tells CBS News that that
idea is being discussed Tony all right
Nancy thank you